pub
[Musique]
et
nous
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
la mcit fille
vous n'avez pas je suppose l'attention
de me faire une référence chaque fois
que nos regards se croisent si votre
grâce
cette intention est louable mais vous
aurez l'obligeance de l'abandonner
vous n'avez pas été engagée pour faire
des exercices d'assouplissement mais
pour tenter de nous servir
de surcroît je ne suis pas la reine
d'angleterre dieu merci en effet votre
branche
nous voici au moins d'accord sur un
point une petite révérence le matin une
petite le soir nous voudrais bien vous
limiter à ces deux démonstrations l'a
bien votre art vous avez découvert c'est
très bien n'oubliez jamais les gazettes
sur la table du déjeuner du matin
nous y tenons beaucoup de plus leurs
lectures à la vente à limiter les
conversations oiseuses que peuvent
entreprendre des esprits malveillants
oui votre grave encore que nous soyons
une famille de gens très
exceptionnellement des fonds oui donc
vous savez le porridge et lola ou de
tous les matins à 6 heures même le
dimanche
non dimanche vous le servait à 5h30 nous
allons à l'office au village à cet
apparent que vous nettoyer la maison de
fond en comble quelques revers de
fortune nous oblige à vivre quasi en
lambeaux et dans des ruines mais j'exige
que ses lambris service soit immaculé
derrière affolé long trop grasse enfin
aussi un peu un autre genre valeur ne
savent pas mais je le regrette pour vous
puisque vous êtes londonienne mais vous
semblez être majeur ayant choisi de
venir ici vous voudrez bien vous
habituer à nos coutumes
de plus nous avons l'habitude de faire
par goût autant que par principe le
contraire de ce qui se fait en
angleterre veut notre grâce souveraine
marc histoire l'a payé assez cher
ceci posé j'ai encore une ou deux
petites choses à vous expliquer vous
n'avez encore vu personne
si vous grâce j'ai vu un monsieur qui se
baignait tout à l'heure dans la pièce
d'eau tout lu
superbe c'est mon fils tort puis il est
en effet subi je vous trouve assez
sympathique
elle a été mariée pas son genre de
confidences sans fil vous avez déjà eu
l'honneur donc de voir le mark
c'est quelqu'un de très violents et de
très tendre vous serez si par hasard il
vous remarque à la fois sa victime et
son idole ne le provoquait pas ils vous
tuerai c'est encore un enfant mais
c'était jal c'est grâce si j'ai bonne
mémoire
au final le marquis mon second fils
plutôt mon second beau fils il a après
l'oubli toi demi-frère un demi-frère qui
d'ailleurs n'y ait rien et qui lui a
redonné là je vous en prie ne posez pas
de questions idiotes j'ai déjà assez mal
de retrouver mam le maroc mon second
d'office et le fils du défunt du cmo
dernier mari de la première duchesse
10ème à la même richesse c'est un être
très fragile il est lui de nouveau un
enfant les temps rempli tout à fait un
homme vous saisissez il fera s'il vous
plaît l'objet de tous vos soi ceci ne
vous autorisons en rien à négliger le
service de ma belle-fille l'aider china
leduc le marquis les dix inédits china
est un an maintenant pas ma fille mais
je la considère comme ma fille me suivez
oui ou non vous ne pouvez pas suivre
perdu tout de suite l'habitude de me
parler comme une malade
comment pourriez vous suivre les dix
chinois et la fille de mon précédent
mari enfin de celui qui dans ma vie a
précédé le feu duc et de sa seconde
femme elle ne met rien mais je les ai
élevés et j'adore à ce que la lapident
lady china est à petit être de cristal
elle a déjà beaucoup voyagé est la même
et là c'était une fois à paris anf a
raconté paris là où habite le roi je ne
sais plus le nom de ce petit château
mais il est resté de cristal
ça je ne le répéterai jamais assez d'eux
tristar de cristal j'ai noté c'est
pourquoi elle pourrait être ma puis il
ya aussi les enfants
ah parce que dix enfants jeudi les
enfants parce que ce sont des enfants
mais ils ne sont pas mes enfants
j'aimerais à votre g non vous ne voyez
rien malheureux
2 bruce et donald sont deux petits
trésors que j'ai adopté ne voulant pas
que thor quils vivent dans la solitude
des garçons unique a d'ailleurs il
pourrait être leur père à peu de choses
près je crois comme un peu trompé sur
l'âge des bébés toujours est il que je
les adore vous voudrez bien j'ai pris le
faire aucune différence entre eux et les
autres petits
quelles que soient leurs clans et les
couleurs de leur start up
bonjour maman
opposée ce bougeoirs perdu s'il fait
déjà deux rangées par la demoiselle
comment allez vous comment allez-vous
notre g vas-y mairie fric
notre nouvelle servant elle est arrivée
hier de londres pendant que vous donniez
briques
elle est charmante et acculer son prénom
ça y est ça commence dès l'aube
mettez-vous là et prenez votre réseau
lisez donc ces deux petits trésors que
c'est un usage que sa soeur china à lui
a appris à son tour de versailles
ça y est j'ai retrouvé le nom du petit
château français versable c'est charmant
non on le dit votre grâce mes chéris
voici mairie prix qui va remplacer
gédéon elle est anglais travers madame
début la tête
miss quick n'est ni française ni mariés
comment allez vous mettez vous là tous
les deux à côté de fer bus et coupé lui
sont là donagh ils sont exclus vous
aurez peut-être un peu de mal avec
monsieur donald il a des idées très
arrêtées mais c'est un coeur d'or et
déjà un excellent film monsieur bruce
vivia d'être très malade
des petits boutons partout on a
d'ailleurs dû lui raser la tête
c'est pour ça qu'il est si calme torque
will excusez moi bonjour
[Applaudissements]
comment allez vous comment allez vous
alors vous vous connaissez j'ai vu
madame pendant qu'il me regardait
prendre mon bain mais je ne regardais
pas les bâtons de distraction ici madame
mais miss prisé mais voyez vous
l'amabilité d'attaché ma manche et quand
vous avez fini de nous examiner comme
des animaux féroces dans une fête
foraine
vous pourrez et moi allons couler les
aiguilles et moi même oh ben non je le
voulais creuser pour une fois vous le
prendrez pouilly faire pour ça je vous
en prie le m'exaspérer pas de si bon
matin
si sa grâce du budget écoutez moi je
vous interdis d'après le duc sa grâce
devant moi c'est une chose à laquelle je
n'ai jamais pu m'habituer gérant voyons
serviteur qui sorties nettes à le faire
cette appellation est déjà complètement
ridicule en ce qui me concerne
étant donné le peu de charme qui me
reste votre grâce à sa merci mais en ce
qui le concerne lui nous touchons
véritablement à l'aberration bien votre
bras là qui vient d'entrer ses les deux
films avec le département c'est la
cérémonie de présentation
je suis exténué aller rechercher du thé
ah ouais annonce huîtres non pas du tout
mon grand amour et puisque vous y tenez
par queen
oui je vous ai vu ce matin décidément en
rêve
c'est drôle quoi votre rêve c'est vous
qui la peau drôle
le rêve lui était charmant hôtel vous
étiez charmant drôle vous avez juré de
me faire pleurer acquis à qui est ce que
je sais tout ce que vous préférez à la
fille du boulanger l'idiote qui sert à
boire au relais à votre cette terre est
la femme du métayer à son fils si vous
pensez que l'une ou l'autre de ces
créatures sont en mesure de me faire
jurer quoi que ce soit vous êtes encore
plus soft que je n'imaginais elle du
moins vous approche par nous tous chez
moi chez moi si vous voulez mais ne
parlez pas toutes ces bêtises distrayez
je vous en train de lire une histoire
fascinante sur toi sur la jalousie et
dangers qu'elles présentaient leurs
conséquences il paraît qu'on en meure
six mois la libye c'est quand on exige
maladroitement ce que les gens adroit
obtiennent sans le moindre effort
je ne comprends rien vous êtes
convalescent brousse
cela n'a rien à voir avec la guérison a
ajouté zizou un peu fatigué votre
préférence ne m'a pas du tout est fait
maison mais si mais si fatigue fergus
ceux-là sont tout ce que vous faites des
tâches partout sur le ce que donald de
vous des de nettoyer son frère et avec
quoi les toiles elles s'aggravent autres
grâce avec mes ongles ou peut-être peut
prendre un torchon non par exemple lancé
la chasse et la chasse est lancée
bientôt 10 qui balaiera qui poussera qui
lavera qui pensera les chevaux qui
nourrira la meute vous peut-être au
moment là me parfaitement la meute
il ya de petites meutes non je vais
d'ailleurs aller voir mon sens les
chiots il n'en finissent pas de naître
direct le contexte
vous allez maintenant vague et sans cela
vous fera le plus grand bien de respirer
un peu pour une fois que barack h
en voulant lèvera tout à l'heure du
reste vous serez croate et jusqu'aux
rangs rentrer et puis vous mangez
beaucoup trop sera pas dans finit plus
alors venez venez et vous aussi les
garçons oui puisque vous parlez du
helmand pourquoi êtes-vous si
désagréable avec moi je ne suis pas
désagréable je suis ailleurs c'est tout
y est
oui ailleurs elle aimait carré tout ceci
va tarder vous tue pas triste je ne
serai jamais je suis furieux j'ai bien
peur d'être toujours que je suis là
enfin je pourrais être là on va faire
pour dormir pour nager pour manger avec
vous pour vous empêcher de mourir 9
fureur mais fait pendant 18 ans
s'il ne devrait plus vous amuser
beaucoup sont pas du reste des jeux
auxquels je crois encore avoir envie de
jouer du moins avec vous avec kido alors
vous pourriez vous comprendre vous êtes
une petite fille et je n'ai pas besoin
d'une petite fille
je suis votre frère était pas une soeur
dont j'ai besoin voilà mon en plus ce
n'est pas un frère dont j'ai besoin
imbécile nous sommes du même di d'or
quils j'ai été votre seul ami notre seul
compagnon
c'est peut-être de cela que vous
punissez je veux autre chose
autre chose que vous tous y apprenez
autre chose on est tout ce que vous
voudrez prenez toutes les vacances dont
votre corps a besoin mais ne me traitez
pas en ennemis je ne suis pas de recours
il je vous aime je ne vais pas vous
m'aimiez passé ne m'appelez pas mon
chéri c'est à moi de dire ma chérie
quand j'en aurais envie c'est à moi de
choisir c'est à dire de choisir tel cas
qui vive
je ne veux pas du nombre la mienne me
suffit et qui sera ce quelqu'un je ne le
suis pas la bande et il n'importe qui
mais au contraire de vous et non pas de
vous china mais le contraire de vous
tous je ne m'en souvenais pas d'un lâche
vraiment ce n'est pas le dégoût qui vous
éloigne de voir c'est la peur oui la
peur
la peur qu'on découvre du vent derrière
votre insolence la peur que votre beauté
et votre force votre adresse cet ajout
d'attirer vers vous tous que le comté
compte de coeur sans jugement et de
cordes inoccupés s'amusant de vous
entendre mot dire tout ce que vous aimez
j'aime cette modeste c'est vous qui
l'avez d'il ya 2 minutes
jamais je n'ai dit que vous étiez tout
ce que j'aime comment aurais-je pu dire
ne pensant pas mon chef l'habitude que
j'ai de vous ne confondez pas tout
imaginez vous il vous plaît que je ne
suis pas encore assez de ma personne je
n'imagine rien je constate
je serais curieux de savoir qui s'y
intéressent à votre personne vous n'avez
pas dîner en ville depuis 18 mois
vous savez pas danser nous n'avons pas
reçu une visite depuis noël il n'y a pas
un garçon présentable a vaincu à la
ronde
vous oubliez mon petit ami que j'ai
simplement un peu plus vécu que vous
vous oubliez que j'ai beaucoup voyagé et
que si j'ai choisi de vivre en solitaire
c'est que le monde que je connais bien
que je connais trop me fait horreur le
monde
oui le monde que le paysan que vous êtes
n'ont jamais approché la branche fera
jamais car les russes tout comme vous
n'y a pas de place
oui le monde kim a fêté comme une
princesse pendant mon voyage en france
tandis que monsieur perdait son temps à
courre le cerf noir relevé attaque comme
dans la gadoue les allures d'un cendrier
je lis voyage 30 jours de repos passer
une nuit à paris
portel lendemain plie à versailles faire
une lieux tels une révérence à leur
reine et repartir séance tenante pour
edimbourg
vous avez vécu en effet pardon madame
pardon il y à des nuits pleines de
lumière en titre quils vous en
connaîtrez peut-être ça m'étonnerait
mais tout est possible
tu dit plein de lumière à 14 ans rien je
préfère temps cela vous voir pleurer sur
votre ignorance de tout ce que j'ai
connu de tous qui a illuminé ma jeunesse
et m'attend là bas tout ce qui vous
attend là bas
parlons-en
peut-être dressé en permanence sur la
place royale des gens qui meurent de
faim la sauvagerie au pouvoir votre
grande amie marie on peut être en prison
tout ce qui est on n'a pas une
provinciale ne parlant pas un mot de
français et parle en anglais que les
anglais comprennent sa peine ils sont
patients labat vous attendre les amants
saft à londres quel salon vous avez des
amants je n'ai pas tellement d'ailleurs
et j'ai encore un amant pauvre ange
dieudegard vous avez vu la mort vous
savez bien d'abord vous avez eu un amant
français celui-là je vous somme de
répondre
les bébés sont arrivés prix brics et
pour l'atteinte celle tard sa tâche du
petit à petit la tâche de sa grâce aux
ducs vous appelez le duc le petit vous
perdez la tête non il ne s'agit
d'ailleurs pas de cela a porté tout de
suite deux grands coussins très mou pour
les enfants d'agata qui viennent
d'arriver
les enfants viennent d'arriver oui
imaginez vous ben vous regardez pas
comme une demeurée qu'est-ce que cela
d'extraordinaire ou bien votre grâce au
point mon anglais alors je mets deux
couverts de plus à midi pour quoi faire
pourquoi faire pour qu'il mange quoi
porter cette fille me rendre à folle
haga times hkl bus
si ç'avait été une parente j'aurais dit
mademoiselle agapa les enfants de
mademoiselle agatha viennent d'arriver
pourquoi pas au point où on en traite ce
que je vous dis et dès que vous serez
revenus du chenil vous irez désherber la
terrasse avant de préparer le déjeuner
ce sera tout pour ce matin oui
probablement
il faut que le parlement fait vite je
suis des banques qui n'a besoin ni de
courant de quoi ces projets quels
projets vraiment shimaoré pelle avoir
des preuves que ces projets français
enfin de quoi parlez vous qu'est ce que
la france pourrait avoir à faire dans
les projets de china c'est par bonheur
elle en avait vous ne savez donc bien je
sais que ce portrait grotesque de votre
arrière grand tante qui était d'ailleurs
plus ou moins française à la suite de je
ne sais quel mésalliance meudal envie de
vendre et quand je ne parviens pas à le
déposer le premier peut être m'aider
quand il a été à versailles at elle vu
cette dame
vous révélez morte il ya sentant lieu
coupé la tête on ne coupe pas la tête à
tout le monde en france que je sache
du moins pas tout le temps c'est un pays
assez primitif évidemment mais qui n'est
pas en état de délire permanent fin je
le crois ça y est cette vielle aure
racing je vais ranger ce débris à caves
mais bon non non séoul où il a vécu ça
n'est pas dans l'écurie non derrière
nathan ne veut pas voir les chevaux sale
bête mais ce prix est oui monsieur des
sales bêtes
vous allez me dire que ça ne vous
regarde pas mais mon ami un homme
superbe dans votre genre mais en plus
fort qui était à oxford oxford
oui monsieur c'est un petit village près
de londres où il était dit que chez les
mecs il est mort d'un coup de pied de
cheval dans les reins si vous me passez
l'expression alors vous pensez les
chevaux je n'ai pas merci mon ami et moi
ça n'avait plus très fort si tu étais un
homme qui mangeait pas qui ne buvaient
pas qu'il dansait pas toujours les
chevaux suis pas une fille d'ailleurs il
en est mort vous allez me dire que je
suis bavarde mais jeunes 106 lois du
pays ici mais je vous trouve bon je sais
pourquoi mais moi la bouteille
et puis je déparle a alors si où
l'écurie m'a dit moi
avez-vous jamais été en france en dieu
non je tiens à la vie avez-vous jamais
connu de français jouit ainsi elle ya
longtemps à oxford
bilan il vous aimer dieu nous c'était un
cardinal qui était venu rendre visite à
l'évêque de mon ami tout en rouge tout
le monde du baiser la main mais un péno
re non c'était plutôt joli à voir
merci à gauche ni dieu il n'a pas quand
le prince s'aperçut que sa fiancée ne
l'aimé plus et qu'elle voulait c'est de
se marier avec le roi du pays et wasabi
et hiboux un grand verre de whisky pour
se donner du courage
et puis il lui fit couper la tête à cet
essai vous qu'est-ce qu'il ya cheminotes
et taisez vous allez allez jouer tous
les deux à la guerre froide sous
l'escalier la plus rapide rappelez-vous
la guerre froide ça doit être très très
silencieux parce que si vous parlez
l'ennemi en temps tout ce que vous dites
et il gagne avec on peut enfin aller à
lui même qu'est ce qui lie à mon petit
chou et la
je ne suis pas votre petit aux recrues
et je me suis le petit aux recrues de
personnes mais sitôt quils vous êtes mon
petit fils bon gré mal gré on n'arrive
pas à mon âge 85 ans sans que presque
tous soit votre petit quelque chose même
maman dans le cas particulier pour une
fois que l'expression ma petite moment
un sens vous êtes
malheur vous a fait du mal m'a pas fait
de mal vous vous êtes fait du mal
j'ai l'air d'une vieille bête je sais
bien je suis très vieux et un peu bête
bien sûr le petit train un peu plus
vieux que il me paraît un peu moins bête
qu'on ne le croit ce sont mes petites
vacances à moi à la fin d'une longue
longue existence de vieux duke
venez la baguette par les siens et la
vie le monde les rois sait faire sans
son père et notre chère maman vous
verrez vous verrez tort puis lorsque
vous aurez mon âge leur peau qui lie à
être celui que l'on excuse parce qu'il
est d'un autre temps déjà donc dans
l'autre monde ou presque
alors qui est il en petit fergus
chinaaid en train de devenir folle il
faut faire quelque chose quoi elle veut
aller en france je voulais dire deuxième
vol est en effet oui mais là ça n'est
pas là le signe manifeste de la folie
des tic vervins en france pourquoi il
faire elle aime elle aime la france à
moi je dois dire que l'étape qui étend
remarquer qu'il ya deux ans elle
adorerait y l'angleterre allure à elle
n'aime pas la france
lm en france qu'est ce qu'ils aiment en
france un français je suppose
pauvre enfant court à sa perte
mais je vais en parler
non non non elle va croire encore que je
fais une de mes crises si si si il faut
que je lui en parle pas plus au nom non
pas parce que si je lui enfin elle va
vous connaissez des français des
français louis des français au nom des
françaises
les françaises un des françaises j'ai un
tout petit peu connu une française puis
un soir à londres comme quand j'avais
votre âge mais que papa ben y'a que papa
avait eu l'idée diabolique qui nous
ad'ailleurs brouillé avec tout le monde
demande et assister au couronnement de
je ne sais plus qui du roi probablement
bah oui oui probablement
alors comment est elle à vous savez je
l' ai très peu vu il était très tarn
nous venions de dîner chez les mâles
bros wii nous nous rentrions à pied
alors nos gens étaient complètement
ivres morts comme d'habitude
eh bien je veux un papa à papa s'était
arrêté un instant dans le parc pour y
apprendre en respirant appelez moi je
rentrais marché tout doucement vers
saint gilles hélas cette dame marché
aussi et elle marchait devant moi elle
semblait d'ailleurs avoir marché une
bonne partie de la nuit venant d'où nous
avons cheminé un peu ensemble un
brouillard est pilotable de 1,22 film
lui-même en bon dieu de marche je suis
sûr c'était une française
c'est effrayant il perd tout petit en
début qu'avez vous qu'avez vous ayez la
cause anti seniors de support mais c'est
bon qu'il fallait à tout prix
qu'avez-vous que j'avais dit mais je
tends queen mois et les chevaux je suis
trompé de porte tu entres dans l'écurie
attendait n'a pas été non non après tout
j'ai rencontré dans la voiture de poste
voilà le courrier une lettre pour vous
tant qu il est pour moi maman rien là
c'est aux franges et une pour moi mais
qu'est ce que vous attendez vous n'avez
pas qu'est ce que c'est que cette lettre
un sens et quand cette chrétienne
puisque rien écrit avec son ratoma
parole qu'elle stimule la demande
jordan qui dit maman fergus vous m'avez
interrompu les oreilles votre ridicule
française de londres en traduisez mois
ceci en langage clair il me semble que
c'est du français
maman m'a fait cette demoiselle dans ma
poche exactement après alors lisez ces
moments c'est bien la peine d'avoir une
versailles et paris à vos pieds vous
n'entendez rien bien entendu une seconde
vous permettez cette personne et que
dire impossible
faites un effort gina madame la duchesse
paris ne sera jamais plus paris comprend
n'a pas été long mais pour l'amour du
ciel tenter de comprendre interpréter
que diable le roi louis va sans doute
avoir la tête tranchée dans quelques
semaines allons bon
mes proches ne valent guère mieux il y a
manifestement quelques mauvais jours à
passer compter sur les suisses serait
folie quoi sur quoi les suisses c'est
quoi les flics c'est un moment oui non
de continuer mais qui n'a que faire
madame que faire je vous le demande
moi aussi je me le demande votre
ambassadeur à paris vous adresse l'épave
que je suis devenu j'arrive madame
j'arriverai jeudi le match de mon
respect etc voilà petit paquet qui sent
sa lettre anonyme à plein des quais les
pende sont signés h et recule de
saint-brice salé lettre anonyme signée
et les plus dangereuses lettre anonyme
gardez la tête qu'elle fait enfin reçu
sa lettre anonyme est elle assez attendu
sa lettre anonyme qu'est ce qui vous
prend à torpiller de prendre cette
créature se moque de nous maman et que
moi vivant jamais cet hercule mettra les
pieds chez nous parce que tant qu il n'a
qu'un but qui est de briser mon vol
votre bonheur
oui oui son bonheur son bonheur qu'elle
est allée chercher chez les sauvages
chez les sauvages qui sont jetés sur
elle sur une enfant commencé chez seul
commencé chez les américains voulez vous
je vous prie éclairé la nuit ou me
plonge les réflexions de votre frère ces
mots ce qu'est la demo ce que dit une
maman est toujours beau mon chéri
qu'elle entend poursuivre et china cette
autre femme maman que je dois vous
parler
pourquoi pour ne pas être constamment
interrompu par les vociférations de
recours tant quils laissez nous s'il
vous plaît avec joie on avait perdu sa
maman et china veulent se parler entre
femmes
alors s'il vous reste une once de
virilité
c'est ça s'entend
[Applaudissements]
maman vous savez comme je vous aime je
vous aime plus que tout je voudrais que
vous écoutiez très gentiment ce que j'ai
à vous dire qui est terriblement
difficile à dire quand on ma chérie rien
et terriblement difficile à dire à
quelqu'un qui vous aime et vous savez
que je vous ai moi aussi plus que tout
que je vous aime tous les 5 plus que
tout vous m'intimider dans maman non mon
amour je ne vous en dit pas c'est le
général que je suis obligé d'être qui
vous intimide celle qui vous punit c'est
quand vous étiez petite celle qui fait
les comptes
celle qui se lève trop tôt et qui se
couche trop tard que trop de bruit rade
parfois et qui ne sait plus sourire de
sa fatigue
celle enfin qui on demande ce miracle
d'avoir des enfants qui ne sont pas le
sien et qu'elle adore qui vous intimide
même moi je ne vous en dit pas ne
laissez pas le rôle qu'il faut bien que
je joue vous cachez votre meilleur ami
parlez moi comme anne maman quand vous
étiez plus quand j'étais jeune ma chérie
mais aujourd'hui où on vieillit sitôt
que vous étiez plus jeune avant le duc
avant mon père avant tout cela équivaut
heureuse sûrement je ne le savais pas
mais je l'était sûrement pourquoi ne le
saviez vous pas parce que j'étais une
petite fille qui vivait dans un grand
château loin de la ville que je tendait
l'oreille pour écouter une musique de
bal qui jamais ne me parvenaient et que
les garçons qui m'entourent n était qu
mes frères peut-être aussi aimait
chasser ne pas être heureuse ou du moins
me croire malheureuse la plupart d'entre
nous se souviennent dans ce rien de la
détresse de leurs 20 ans et puis il y en
a quelques unes
jusqu'à 100 ans reste ces jeunes filles
à fantômes ses fantômes de jeunes filles
health en oublie de mourir dans leur
chagrin les préoccupent
chaque siècle enfin une ou deux de ces
fleurs à l'élégance de disparaître à
peine éclose elle inspira leur raconte
qui fait pleurer tout le monde ou une
pièce de théâtre qui distrait prendre en
une heure ou deux les gens des villes
lesquels des jeunes filles avez vous été
regardez-moi china et je lève avoir
jamais été destiné à une ville fantôme
ce qui est pire à 8 morte
oui mais moi maman je ne suis pas votre
vraie fille et la femme a chéri on ne
devient pas champion de lutte sans
quelques exercices se sont tous les
exercices auxquels j'ai rompu mon coeur
qui m'ont donné ma force
lorsque j'avais votre âge moi aussi je
me cramponne à mes rêves pour éviter de
me réveiller et puis un jour est venue
quelques a bien voulu s'appuyer sur mon
bras
et puis un autre d'autres encore et puis
vous tous il a bien fallu que ce jour là
je me réveille il va bien falloir que
vous aussi à ma table cc dormir mais je
ne dors pas j'attends attendez vous je
pense que vous attendiez quand vous
aviez 20 ans j'attends qu'on me tende
les mains j'attends d'avoir envie d'être
joli d'avoir envie de fouiller dans les
armoires géante du premier étage pour y
découvrir de quoi m'aider à être plus
jolie encore j'attends que la porte
s'ouvre pour pouvoir partir pour partir
ou pour le voir entrer ma petite fille
il n'y a pas de porte assez forte pour
empêcher de partir ce qu'ils veulent
partir
il n'y en a pas non plus d'assez fortes
pour arrêter qui veut d'entrée ce que
vous attendez là peut-être derrière
notre porte
hésitant à entrer il fut croit maman je
suis sûr comme vous avez de la chance
[Rires]
quelles sont vos intentions au sujet de
la lettre à ma foi je lis nord il s'agit
de savoir s'il y en a voulu me faire une
plaisanterie diotte aussi ce malheureux
a effectivement besoin de nous encore
convaincu que ce n'est pas loupé les
entrées d'où vient cette conviction
je connais cet homme vous le connaissez
lui un peu c'est moi qui à paris lui ai
dit où nous vivions il devait m'écrire
mais sa femme était très jalouse
la pauvre qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire est pourquoi la pauvre parce
qu'elle est morte
du moins je l'espère c'est trop gentil
j'espère pour elle parce qu'elle était
très très malade mais pourquoi n'avez
vous jamais parlé tout cela j'avais peur
que vous ne compreniez pour voyous china
comment espérez vous que je comprenne
qu'un homme marié tombe amoureux d'une
enfant de 14 ans qu'il a à peine vu et
probablement sans comprendre amoureux de
ce qu'elle disait mais nous ne parlions
pas nous désignons vous désignez quoi
des petits coeurs des petites flèches
des petits arcs comme on fait sur les
arbres les statuts le dimanche dans son
pays
un détail il n'y a pas d'arbres de
statut qu'ils ne soient couverts de
coeur de flèches de date initiale c'est
monstrueux
oh non ça doit les aider à pousser à ne
pas s'abîmer
tout est si beau là bas qui vous a
permis de faire connaissance
la reine la reine louis marraine la
ressortie du château quand j'y entrais
conforter la lettre à notre cousin du
royal écossais qu il y avait beaucoup de
monde devant la cour pour la regarder
passer on était très serré j'étais serré
contre lui il m'a pris la main il m'a
dit que c'était la reine
puis il m'a invité à boire de la
limonade et à manger de la brioche comme
le peuple sous une tonnelle dans le
village
comment est-il tout petit très sale avec
des lanternes partie par là qu'il est
clair très mal voyons chine or je parle
de ce monsieur au pardon très grand très
propre de flash fissures il me
dévisageait tout le temps et il m'a dit
je vous aime cet original en quoi vous
at il dit comme ça en anglais très
lentement
je vous aime tout ceci est
fantastiquement embarrassant
je vous promets impardonnable de ne pas
m'avoir parlé plus tôt mais maman je ne
peux pas chaque fois qu'un garçon me dit
qu'il m'aime je ferai quand tous les
garçons que je croise le disque il même
ceux que je croise à la ville ceux qui
viennent travailler ici c'est normal
mais je ne les entendra je ne vois pas
moi tu plonges shima réfléchissez si je
reçois ce français comment
s'appelle-t-il plus l'icône de saint
brice 1 il est vu comme en ce moment
c'est pas énorme surtout chez eux
c'est mieux que rien si je reçois se dit
qu'on est il va être convaincu que vous
l'aimez que vous l'attendiez
il va s'incruster ici vous allez
peut-être le haïr dans dix jours
il est lois de l'hospitalité qu'en
faites vous ah non vous avez vous lu
votre hercules vous aurez votre hercules
dieu sait que nous allons au-devant des
pires difficultés mais moi vivant tu
m'apportes ne sera jamais fermée aux
étrangers
quelle que soit leur confession ou leur
couleur mais il est blanc j'espère bien
et vous allez me faire le plaisir de le
recevoir poliment tout en évitant de
vous jeter à sa tête bien entendu tâche
est de saisir la nuance mais non mais
non ce n'est pas effrayant et les
français c'est entendu mais il est dit
qu au monde c'est une petite
compensation
et puis de toute façon il est trop tard
pour discuter quand at il dit qu'il
allait arriver jeudi bonté divine c'est
demain c'est demain c'est horrible ce
qui est en règle c'est la façon insensée
dont fonctionne la poste en province
fait pas penser en paréo leur mère est
allé me chercher les enfants s'ils
veulent se veut souple est là le travail
votre grave pour s'enlever il y a le
montant que vous êtes ici je ne sais pas
votre grâce
le temps passe si vite quand on
travaille vous avez bien entendu écouté
toute la conversation que j'ai eue avec
lady chine à caen jasse tic votre grâce
je n'entends rien je n'ai pas à ce
ticket mon homme menace est souvent
reproché mais cause astique gisti dans l
avant vous me ferez le plaisir
d'astiquer les dans votre cuisine comme
tout le monde retourne ici alors je mets
un couvert de plus demain au dîner pour
le français
vous n'imaginez pas suppose que nous
allons recevoir ce gentilhomme comme
nous recevons le vicaire du village nous
y passerons la nuit mais elle sera reçue
dignement
vous n'avez sans doute jamais entendu
parler de l'hospitalite écossaise non
mais j'ai entendu parler de
l'hospitalité anglaise vous allez
pouvoir enfin faire la comparaison entre
les deux vous serez attendu d'avoir un
pied dans la tombe pour la faire mais
vous allez la faire comme une garantie
commencé d'ores et déjà à ratisser la
cour d'honneur et fait le lit dans la
chambre du prétendant charles-edouard
vous n'avez que le temps jamais comment
ça mais je ne fais le ninos tu as ne
s'agit malheureusement pas te faire le
lit des histoires perdu vous la tête à
grasse me dit de faire ligue prétend
dont je réponds à sa grâce mais le
prétendant
paix à son auguste mémoire est décédé il
ya deux ans ils rentrent c'est le lit où
il a fait la sieste l'après-midi quand
il avait 18 mois il y à 77 ans de cela
il ya prescription faut pas ça alors ça
va s'il ya prescription ça va vive l
approche et mes enfants
elle voit tout même derrière elle je
vous l'avais dit quelle existence mes
enfants j'ai décidé de donner asile à
hercules hockey à hercules à monsieur de
saint brice dieu sait que la malheureuse
créature a droit à plus d'un titre
un maître hospitalier à plus d'un titre
en effet à plus d'un titre
en effet et je ne pense pas qu'il soit
l'un d'entre vous qui s'oppose à la
décision que je viens de prendre six
mois parce que quinn qui ignorent la
bonté et la charité que la pitié
n'hésiterait pas à laisser dans la
misère un ami ou la providence a fait
une épave une épreuve au nunavut
attendons vous avez tout à attendre et
quand cela serait un moment vous ne vous
rendez pas compte que les vouvray du
malheureux qui ne vous rendez pas compte
enfin votre vie va avoir un but de
l'abrutissement qui s'est emparée de
chacun ici pas grâce à sa tête durable
victime trouver une raison d'être
anéantie on a joué non on ne va pas
jouer rester nous allons procéder avant
en ce qui concerne la réception ou la
non réception de monsieur de simpliste
comme il s'agit d'un français nous
voterons à malves et c'est l'occasion ou
jamais qui est pour un pourquoi le des
lamas fergus vous êtes pour évidemment
vous les enfants vous êtes pour
également levé la matinale de lever la
main bruce lever la main je vous en fait
vous coucher moi aussi maman chérie je
suis pour moi aussi je suis pour a oui
maman je suis pour
pour que votre fille pour que ma soeur
pour que votre surf airbus pour que
votre soeur à vous aussi introduisent au
sein de la famille un satyre un satyre
français de surcroît où je suis pour la
voir comment il va être accueilli se
réfugier
c'est précisément vous qui allait
l'accueillir de recul il n'est pas
question que la pauvre chose puisse
trouver le chemin du château
après le cauchemar d'un voyage qui
l'aura mené à une âme
vous allez donc partir sur le champ à sa
rencontre allemand et le ramener ici
briques pris aux bouchers donald aller
la chercher la malheureuse est sourde
comme un tapis voyez voyez il a dit
qu'il serait de jeudi à edimbourg
arrangez-vous pour les découvrir ce sera
d'ailleurs d'éléments élémentaire oui
vous qui l'accompagnent pour
m'accompagner manquerait plus que cela
donc oui la raison ma chérie ce serait
peut-être mais sûrement de m'accompagner
pas je me débrouillerai tout seul je
vous le garantis je vous demanderai
simplement me dire à quoi il ressemble à
quoi il ressemble il n'y aura pas deux
s'affrontaient à l'auberge du relais je
pense ou le reconnaîtra facilement un
étranger un grand entraîneur étranger
sera aussi difficile
précisément notre pays vous l'ignorez
peut-être est infesté d'aider les
français à voter délicat alors puis-je
savoir qu'elle ait l'air de cette
créature de rêve le contraire du veau
aux trotteurs quils l'air d'un homme
élégant raffiné aimable âme esprit
appelé mais appelez immédiatement daisy
au tilbury et mettez un petit paquet de
paille de pathé dans la voiture mais ce
que thor où il part pour la miss
malaisie la jument jamais trouvé pas mal
moi même mais il ne va t elle pas de
harnais ni de celle que j'irais à pied
trompe heureux enfin je vous retrouve
maintenant vous me retrouver vous disiez
donc bien élevé et élégant raffiné
aimable vous ne pouvez pas le manquer ça
je m'y emploierai compter sur moi soit
je portais ce gentilhomme quelques
messages particuliers oui dites-lui
voulez vous que la personne que ma mère
lui envoie lui représente assez bien les
motifs que j'ai de la tendre très
impatiemment
merci votre message a oui dites lui s'il
vous plaît que un soir dans le
brouillard de landreau
g j'ai bien aimé son beau pays maman dit
lui tord prix que ma porte lui est
ouverte grande ouverte mais que
j'aimerais bien qu'il la referme
derrière soi très solidement après être
arrivé chez nous j'adore les arrivées et
les départs de fautes horreur c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi comment allez vous je suis le
monsieur de france comme moi et vous
serez heureux ce moi aussi monsieur vous
avez une très jolie maison monsieur vous
trouvez oui je trouve ça très bien l'art
manger je vous attendais nous voulions
faire honneur c'est très gentil
je ne vous dérange pas trop pas du tout
monsieur ma maman est en train de finir
de s'appliquer machine est allé chercher
des à la ferme vous de voir ce chocolat
ont voulu me suivre je vois bien
elle a peut-être ont coupé l'appétit
juste avant de brûler monsieur blanc
joue l'homme de votre maman ne revienne
monsieur vous avez fait bon voyage
oui très bon merci qu'il y avait
beaucoup de vent sur la mer vous avez
traversé la mer forcément pour venir du
continent à il faut traverser la mer
formée très bien l'anglais monsieur je
n'ai appelé à l'écran quand j'étais
petit c'est difficile oui très mais
j'étais très doué et on me prive de
chocolat comme j'avais une mauvaise note
c'est pourquoi je ne sais pas mais si
vous savez moi plutôt que la france est
au bout oui ça vous c'est très beau il
ya parfois du soleil l'île de man
pourquoi et pourrait être obligée
d'aller se coucha juste après le dîner
ce soir elle se colore puisque ont
éveillé
il est arrivé mais sûr que oui puisque
tard il est revenu l'honneur comme en
été je ne sais pas je n'ai pas encore vu
tout doit être de droit français
oui ou par toucher à la table du brusque
et mal attentionnés c'est pour laisser
cette table tranquille petit chenapan
oui
maintenant il faut laisser ce monsieur
lui se préparer pour le souper qu'est ce
que vous faites là avec ces sauts je
mets les flacons de busquets rafraîchir
votre grave
le whisky ce boîtier bus
nous ne sommes pas des barbares on
atteint musarder aller d'onde et les
désirs que monsieur tank où il a laissé
un plan dans la cour et qui est un âge
jamais à jour de la tuerie
soyez gentil donnez moi mais quand la
qui sont sur la table
je vais y aller moi même merci à dans
cette tenue cet agréable moment au
magazine ont pas eu six breaks ou 120
moment vous êtes gentils donald j'essaye
d'être le moins les possibles vous êtes
très beau aussi mes garçons surtout de
droit si nocive et enchaîna aussi même
mais et c'est même la plus belle
moi je m'affaire parcours si j'étais lui
je me marre avec thor oui oui mais
voulait pacifique moi j'aimerais veux me
marier avec china j'ai l'impression que
tout que ça n'est pas possible
longuement garçon ce n'est pas parce que
parce que il me semble bien que china
veut se marier avec quelqu'un d'autre
que vous qui atteint jeunes je crois
qu'il ne sait pas encore très bien avec
qui mais j'ai grand peur que ça ne soit
point avec vous ces parias son âge ça
n'est pas toujours parce que l'on est
grand que l'on sait très bien ce que
l'on veut faire mon cher mais vous ne
savez fergus ouais j'ai pensé parce que
toute ma vie à croire que je ne savais
rien ne jamais le faire
c'est pour ça que je suis encore ici à
me faire
ronde et m me faire me faire dorloter
comme vous d'eux c'est peut-être aussi
bien fergus et peut-être aussi bien
puisque nous avons pu vous garder au
[Applaudissements]
final comme vous êtes jeu l'image aller
comme dans les histoires de santé de ses
patients
allez vite vous laver les mains vous
allez on se fait d'habitude c'est vrai
fergus que je suis jolie mieux que je
lis mon chéri il ne sentait pas je
l'espérais je n'en étais pas très sûr
ce qui est plus joli que tout ce que
sous votre joli corsage
on devine votre joli coeur et derrière
vos jolis yeux tout ce qu'il ressent
vous croyez oui et que ressentie à ça
c'est un secret que je garde pour moi
tirgu s'il vous plaît non non non sind
ne m'obligez pas vous trahir restez dans
votre charmante angoisse
ne laissez pas s'échapper trop vite
cette et minutes des minutes qui sont
les plus tendres de la vie celle où
toulon vacille un peu entre plusieurs
bonheur qui sont à portée de votre main
quel bonheur
je voulais d'ici là vos bonheurs sont
mon secret nous sommes celles où on
n'est jamais seul tous ces vieux murs
sont plaints d'oreille vous croyez faire
qu'est-ce que je vais être heureuse si
vous êtes sages mais je ne suis je suis
trop jeune et pas de votre sagesse de
prêter fille que je parlais mais de
l'autre celle des grandes personnes
celle qui consiste à ne plus être
raisonnable quand il le faudrait 1
comme j'aimerais que vous au moins
vivent y ait une vraie vie china
ce soir je vais à ces rencontres aussi
part qu'elle détourne un ange
que voulez-vous dire rien rien de grave
j'espère le verrons bien à nous de ce
qui vous regarde et vous écoute avec moi
des zips n'a pas du tout semblait me
reconnaît on va mener pagny fois il me
fit se doit être pour ça nous avons
soupé il voit peut-être enfin prête bris
brics adelac l'oise du supply hommes et
enfants
je suis dans un état de nerfs
indescriptible je vous envie d'être si
cannes aux excès calme chez naboo
n'ayons pas l'air d'attendre le messie
tâchez d'être naturel surtout vous faire
non plus imaginer mais nous ne sommes
pas seuls à oser tonale de mettez-vous
là et ne parlez pas avant que ce
monsieur nous interroge sur quoi sur ce
qu'il verra et si vous avez à parler ne
parlait pas la bouche pleine
eh bien oui thil qui commet qui vous
moquez de moi je n'ai pas trouvé
qu'est ce que vous dites je n'ai pas
trouvé vous plaisantez
je ne plaisante pas j'ai même rarement
eu moins envie de plaisanter je n'ai pas
trouvé que c'est impossible
vous n'avez pas cherché cherché j'ai
cherché partout je n'ai pas trouvé c'est
inimaginable vous l'avez vous cherchez
relais dans les auberges dans les
tavernes je ne vais pas trouver alors je
suis revenu savait pas passer ma vie à
chercher votre ami vous avez pu tenter
de nous renseigner le semble vous auriez
pu questionner les voyageurs les cochers
j'ai questionné tout ce qui est est
questionnable
personne ne l'a vu vous l'avez décrit
sinon comment y aller vous décrit comme
vous me l'avez décrit vous-même beau
élégant raffiné
j'ai même ajouté français et on m'a ri
au nez probablement parce que tous ces
adjectifs se marient assez mal il a fait
exprès pourquoi l'aurait fait exprès
quand vous êtes jaloux jaloux comme quoi
c'est l'autre qui selon lui peut pas
l'être
voyons voyons brillante en couille cette
histoire est complètement ridicule
je suis convaincu que si vous l'aviez
chercher correctement vous aviez
rencontré ce monsieur de cinq ans et il
a peut être raté le coche c'est
spirituel y avait été un autre voyageur
s'est rangé je ne sais pas comment vous
ne savez pas comment aurais-je vous
n'étiez pas l'arrivée de la voiture
si j'étais alors vous avez bien vu qu'il
redescende et les étrangers qui voyage
ne portent pas inévitablement une
cocarde aux couleurs de leur pays
en effet mais quand une douzaine de
voyageurs sont attendus un relais avait
pas génial de discerner qui parmi elles
peut-être un exilé français c'est trop
génial pour torpiller en tout cas
pourquoi ne pas aller le chercher vous
même je voulais proposer de le faire ils
me sens parfaitement je m'en souviens
très bien
oui même à moi c'est vous même qui lui
avait déconseillé
je m'en souviens très bien je n'ai
jamais pris fergus n'essayez pas de
brouiller les cartes
la situation telle qu'elle est déjà
assez complet
c'est pas de glace et je voudrais bien
savoir torpille pourquoi vous ne nous
avaient pas avertis de cet incident
extrêmement fâché à votre retour des
tabous au lieu d'attendre que nous
soyons tous prêt à surfer il fallait
bien que je me change aussi pourquoi ce
qu'il n'y avait plus aucune raison de
faire de fête et de s'habiller gina
raison pourquoi et pourquoi vous être
habillé comme pour aller au vol puisque
vous savez mieux que quiconque que le
ballon n'aurait pas lieu
mais pourquoi n'aurait-elle pas lieu
nous n'allons pas je suppose prendre le
deuil parce que ce monsieur est le bon
esprit à la dernière minute de ne pas
venir nous encombrer de cette personne
je savais que toutes les maisons
seraient temps grand habit et il n'y a
aucune raison pour que je sois le seul
arthur cuir bottes
monsieur le vicomte est servi
j'avoue je te supplie sacra cela dit
d'annoncer chalon il n'y a pas de
monsieur le vicomte
monsieur le vicomte n'est pas arrivé au
rendez-vous il retrouver dans notre
cuisine
nous on croit plus tard c'est du sous
fonds commencent à face à donald et vous
dit désolé je suis au bord de la crise
de nerfs tout ceci était monial
vous nous avez placé dans une situation
grave est pas recueilli maintenant
permettez moi de monter dans ma fille en
maintenant ne plus les boules quand vous
mettez vous dans un état pareil quoi me
mettez vous dans un état pareil
- oui vous vous avez très bien que
j'attendais recul de tout mon coeur vous
aviez très bien pris me réjouit c'est
que de tout le monde comme à montréal
recevoir vous red hot wheels je me
réjouissais moi même instrument que
china mépris et accueillant ça veut dire
fou vous voilà tout d'abord enivré à
l'idée d'être les auteurs inconnus dont
vous ne savez rien qui est probablement
un poltron puisqu'il abandonne son pays
en danger
puis sur - pour rien qui n'a qu'un but
celui de se faire nourrir par nous
jusqu'à la fin de ses jours
vous voilà ensuite désespérés parce
qu'un miracle webb a tant manqué au
mieux encore une invitation plus
séduisante que celle que china lui avait
faite il ya quelques années nous
débarrasse de lui juste à venir tout ce
dur vous détestez fluidité parc où il
est je vous interdit d'élever la voix en
ma présence comme vous venez de le faire
c'est que lorsque votre père vous a
confié à moi il m'a fait le plus jeune
est présent qu'un homme puisse faire à
une femme mais ce bonheur que vous
m'avez apporté bien là volontairement
commence à se transformer en calamité
n'obligez pas compris à vous dire tout
ce que j'ai sur le coeur depuis que vous
avez cessé d'être un enfant tout en
négligeant de devenir à non aux mamans
invite le
non si je le dis je serai peut-être
incapable de l'oublier or je tiens à
l'oublier c'est que soit je vais vous le
dire puisque vous y tenez vous avez été
un enfant charmant torque oui et non pas
seulement charmant parce que vous étiez
le plus joli bébé de notre club mais
parce que tous les charmes de la terre
vous avez été distribués en cadeau de
baptême par votre mère dont chacun sait
qu'elles étaient la grâce en personne et
par votre père qui s'il n'avait été un
gentil gamme incomparable et aero ne
serait jamais devenu mon mari vous avez
cessé d'être ce charmant bébé pour
devenir un charmant garçon dont toutes
les petites filles et toutes les mères
de ce pays était éprise et puis peu à
peu nous avons vu votre soeur ou frère
et moi le prince devenir palefrenier
nous avons vu l'arrogance prendre la
place de la distance et la grossièreté
celle de la liberté ni les continuelles
attention de votre soeur nina mans s'il
vous plaît que cet ancien masseur pour
une fois vous avez bien fait de me
couper la parole torque will j'allais
dire une sottise
j'aurais dû dire les continuelles
attention de chine à vous donner
l'occasion de prouver que vous étiez un
homme de goût en goûtant ce qu'elle
voulait bien vous offrir cette occasion
vous l'avez laissé échapper
j'en suis navré pour vous je croyais
vous avoir mieux élevés
ce n'est pas croyez le bien le fait que
vous ayez trouvé ou perdus monsieur de
saint-brice qui tout à l'heure a fait
pousser ce cri la chine à ce que serait
ce alors mon enfant vous n'avez jamais
été très doué pour les langues
ni pour le français ni pour l'allemand
ni même pour l'anglais je constate que
celle que je m'évertue à vous parler
depuis 20 ans où demeurent également
étrangère nous en resterons là pour ce
soir si vous n'y voyez pas
d'inconvénient
aucun moi je ne voulais pas tort quils
je vous plains c'est presque aussi
triste
[Applaudissements]
vous n'auriez pas du tort qu'il a battu
quoi faire ce que vous avez fait je n'ai
rien fait tout détruire vous détruire
que voulez vous dire je veux dire je dis
que vous êtes trop grands maintenant
pour ne pas savoir le prix de certains
sans enjeu mais la douceur avec la kelly
il faut tirer les somnambules de leur
sommeil vous auriez dû être plus fort
qu'une brute ne pas faire ce que vous
avez fait je vous le répète je ne
pouvais rien faire d'autre que de les
fous fous de coiffes ou de pied fou de
solitude faut être tous à la mi chemin
entre autres mamans et vous ébrouer
c'est donald fou de rage contre cette
vie d'enfant que le m'oblige à vivre
foot de pouvoir en vivre une autre parce
que je ne sais rien que personne ne veut
de moi oui vraiment mais je n'ai pas je
suppose que les petites aventures de
vendangeurs ou de moissonneurs que je
peux vivre de temps en temps quand il
vient rayon soleil sur le but de ma vie
et china qu'est ce que vous en faites
finances aux 20,4 pas partir tout de
suite est déjà parti et c'est tant mieux
china me et je ne comprends rien
china est à la tête de cette coalition
demers aveugle deux cousines repoussante
et 13 ans b si tu me détestes c'est pour
moi oui
vous savez maladroit tort qu'ils jouent
savez insolent vous savez injuste mais
mais je ne vous savez pas bête
personne ici ne vous d'été sinon pour
réfugiés dans la colère et
l'impertinence mais les enfants
terribles n'amuse que les gens sans
enfant sachez le
j'avais le malheur de n'avoir point de
fils et j'ai tout mis en oeuvre pour
vous faire accepter d'être le mien je
n'étais peut-être pas un père dont dont
il y ait lieu d'être bien fier mais mes
du mois on était gens qui vous aimait
très fort je ne pouvais vous proposez
que ma complicité pour vous tirer des
mauvais pas vous étiez souvent mais je
vous le ferai du fond du coeur j'espère
et ainsi donner un peu de sérieux à la
fin d'une vie bien inutile alors je me
trompais soir mon petit orc huile
[Applaudissements]
si vous pleurez non je ne perds pas
laissez moi tranquille bien voir ça elle
vous a grondé
non elle ne m'a pas grondé si elle vous
aggravez je n'ai entendu non il ne faut
pas vous êtes un homme
pourquoi ne le regrette il pas maman
qu'est ce que ça veut dire maman
plus rien ni personne n'en sait rien et
vous en faites trop petit pour que je
vous le dise
j'en ai assez embêtant kg pour tous
toujours trop petits ou trop grands pour
tous oui c'est vrai ils sont par terre
c'est pas pourront en avoir pleuré
voyez que ça existe un pays où peu de
soi même
évidemment vous savez pas moi je sais
c'est qu'il ya des garçons qui font le
tour du monde sur des bateaux à voile
grand comme la maison qui sont attendus
par des femmes qui n'ont pas peur de se
jeter dans leurs bras et s'allonger
contre eux en trois jours et trois nuits
faire
pour dormir parce que déjà merveilleux
pour les regarder dormir ce qui est plus
merveilleux encore quand on est bien
varié pourquoi ne vous mariez vous faire
vous êtes assez vieux maintenant avec
kim un virage avec she la chine à cet
oiseau qui joue à la maman avec moi
parce qu'elle est incapable de jouer à
la femme
[Musique]
pourquoi je suis je dit non au recours
c'est bien quand vous racontez des
histoires
moi aussi j'aime bien c'est pas une
histoire comme celle de fergus vous
savez que je connais par coeur
vous l'avez pas lu c'est une histoire
terrible mais n'ayez pas peur et juré
mois donne jamais la dire à qui que ce
soit sinon je vous je vous tue oui il y
avait une fois dans les hautes terres
une fille et un garçon qui lorsqu'il
était très jeune mais bien jouer
ensemble mais bonjour si je puis dire
le garçon s'est aperçu qu'il était
devenu un grand garçon qui devait se
raser pour être propres enfin tout ce
qui avertit qu on est un homme il
trouvait la fille jolie et bien qu'il
détestait les filles il voulu lui dire
mais comme ils ne savaient parler
tendrement comète il ne sut pas les
super tendres et un matin où il avait
décidé de lui demander dans n'importe
quelle langue de lui confier ses jolis
cheveux c'est joliment sa jolie voix
elle annonça qu'elle les avait promis un
voyageur la personne ne connaissait
alors alors alors il courir pendant
toute une nuit par tous les bords des
canaux saône a sonné à toutes les portes
jusqu'à ce qu'il découvre le voleur quel
bonheur
le volant deux filles clip est alors
le trouva enfin une mise au clair sur
ses yeux rabaisse à son chapeau lui
demande alors qu'il était et au moment
où le jour se lever avec le pommeau
d'argent de cinq travaille avec ces
poilus le bâti de toutes ses forces
jusqu'à ce qu'il ne reste plus qu'un
cadavre à ses pieds un cadavre
recroquevillé dans l'eau salée les
ordures de la rigole c'est du levier est
ici en direct vous veillez à man qu'est
ce que vous faites là tous les trois
tant qu'il est en train de nous raconter
une histoire merveilleuse
oui merveilleux c'est l'histoire d'un
voyageur qui bossent pourquoi n'êtes
vous pas plus souvent gentil top 1000
vous savez si bien l'être quand vous
voulez venaient m'embrasser n'oublions
tout cela normalement mais si mais si
oublions le tout ceci n'est pas très
grave dont six moments c'est très grave
maintenant vous verrez tout est réparé à
de l'irréparable qu'en faites vous il
n'y'a d'irréparable que le départ de
ceux qui s'en vont pour toujours mais
nous en sommes bien le voir récemment
venaient m'embrasser
non non je ne peux pas comment pas ce
soir soit 3 3 je ne vais pas me rouler à
vos pieds bruce allez dire à china de
descendre et vous donald dynamique
script de servir
china va arriver
vous avez l'amabilité de ne pas leur
parler de toute cette histoire peut-être
son chagrin passera-t-il en même temps
que votre mauvaise humeur
ça me surprendrait cela me surprendrait
aussi un peu de leur jeu là donnent
gagnante de la bonne longueur dans cette
course à la délicatesse china je
voudrais que vous mangiez quelque chose
avant de vous endormir ma chérie ni ni
fin ni sommet où il faut forcer un peu
chine à quoi à supporter toutes les
heures semblables de tous les jours
semblables de cette ville eu du bon
on vous dramatisez votre vie n'est pas
si l'aide
vous avez encore des années l'ongle vous
avez devant vous avant de l'avoir de
pour l'avoir s'embellir du le croyait je
ne crois plus que faire du sens raison
ma chérie parce que de saint-brice n'est
pas arrivé c'est très décevant
je vous la corde ne calmez-vous ma
petite finir je vous jure que nous
sommes tous navré ici que vous ayez de
la peine n'est ce pas fergus
c'est le moment de dire quelque chose
d'hors queen que voulez vous que je dise
quoi participer participent croyez-moi
je participe participent beaucoup plus
encore que vous n'imaginez ni dont je
jure que moi non plus je ne voulais pas
vous rendre malheureuse
quand comment quand on vous pensez à ne
pas me rendre malheureuse
vous avez commencé par déposer mes
poupées vous êtes ensuite attaqué à mes
traces et vous avez finit par empêcher
quelqu'un que j'adore de venir me
rejoindre pour mais nous ne sommes pas
dans le désert chine en en faisant un
petit effort monsieur 2
ça après ça peut très bien découvrir
notre maison si la seule chose à
laquelle personne ne pense
comment pourrait-il avoir envie de
découvrir des gens qui ne se sont même
pas donné la peine d'aller l'accueillir
désespéré froide si votre ami a vraiment
envie de vous rejoindre et viendra
croyez moi non il ne viendra pas en vous
est insupportable tant couilles dans les
plus longtemps même supporter et
rassurez-vous ce qui veut dire rien qui
vous regardent vous dites et stupidité
pourquoi ce vicomte ne trouvera t'il pas
le chemin du château ce que dit fergus
et plein de bon sens pour une fois merci
maman
non il ne trouvera pas le chemin du
château qu'est ce qui vous fait dire une
chose pareille
répondez au quiz oui dit de ne pas venir
j'en étais sûr vous avez fait cela
répondez-moi temps couilles je vous le
redonne bien vu vous répondre tu vous
répondre des choses vous faire dresser
les cheveux sur la tête
voilà ce que j'ai fait oui j'étais à
edimbourg j'ai cherché ce sens
montbard dont je suis le vicomte de
saint-brice je vous ai envoyé une lettre
vous annonçant la venue ce n'était pas
un geste très discret mais on avait
tellement dit à votre ambassade à paris
montrer monsieur rentrée vous est
probable
vous êtes sans doute oui monsieur c'est
moi je vous présente mes hommages
madame la duchesse je suis dans la
confusion la plus profonde croyez-le de
vous imposer ainsi la présence mais le
malheur a voulu que vous n'avez pas reçu
mon petit mot si si si si mais ce que je
l'assumé
vous ne m'attendais peut-être pas à
cette heure non oui si oui quelles
qu'elles auraient toutefois sous le tas
tard bien tard madame j'ai eu hélas
quelques difficultés à mon arrivée en
ville le désordre de ma toilette en fait
soir à ne voir rien c'est léger était
assez rudement pris à partie en
descendant de voiture par un individu
assez grossier qui me demandaient leur
je lui répondu de plus civilement du
monde
m'at-il semblé lorsqu'il s'est jeté vers
moi avec la avec la plus grande
brutalité et m'a laissé pour mort dans
le ruisseau en jésus maladroitement
employés pour un nouveau autres un mot
qu'il a jugé inconvenant tard je sais
trop que vos compatriotes sont
incapables
je ne sais où j'ai la tête vous
débarrasser de votre petit ça pour
autant de prêts dimanche adam la
duchesse me bon droite au caire
et permettez moi de vous présenter mon
beau-fils fergus du de grosses lan
je suis heureux de vous saluer monsieur
le duc très heureux aussi vicomte et mon
beau fils tom quinn
alors monsieur vous connaître vous
rassemblez fort à quelqu'un qu'il me
semble avoir déjà vu en plus avenant
comment avez-vous mieux merci
avant mes deux fils adoptifs brousse et
donald bonjour arbres ou non ces lots
je vous demande pardon bonsoir donald
commande et vous comment m bonsoir
enfin je ne crois pas avoir besoin de
vous présenter à ma belle fille lady
china aurait reconnu les dix chinois
entre mille jeunes filles comment
allez-vous élevé par vous madame elle ne
pouvait être que la noblesse et le
charmant personnes nous allions souffler
sans plus nous attendrons le faste que
nous voulions déployés pour vous êtes un
peu ébréché hommage à plomelin traduit
chanceux grâce
quelle merveilleuse demain et quelle
jolie coutume que celle de votre pays de
s'habiller pour le dîner elle se perd
chez nous et va naturellement
disparaître étant donné ce qui s'y passe
je ne m'en console pas cette petite
jupette et à nantes
vous aimez avait peut-être voulez vous
prendre le temps de vous changer
non non non je vous ai fait 4 au 14
concernent le voyage est d'ailleurs une
éponge et je n'y a rien de présentable
pour ce soir ni habits ni perruque
si vous m'y autorise et je souffrais
donc dans ce triste qui permet bien
entendu vous devez être bien là monsieur
bien là et très bas avez vous fait pour
moi un voyage possible le fatigant
madame le fatigant une mer démontée des
difficultés sans nombre à la frontière
française
alors qu'à votre des disques port de
douvres en dehors du fait que l'on met
fouillaient des pieds à la tête
tout s'est passé le plus simplement du
monde un bref séjour à londres qui fut
un enchantement un enchantement
vous m'étonnez un quotidien au
brouillard c'est imad hamad aux
sentiments j'ai visité sept riante cité
la tour de londres les docks des
faubourgs de l'est tout cela éclatant de
gaieté vous avez du mal regardé comme
toujours et cette bourgade à côté de vos
admirables site est à vous oui oui très
bien maintenant nous a fait énormément
voyagé torque oui le pauvre chéri n'a
pas pu pousser plus loin que le pays de
galles de choses comment vous consoler
de quitter votre merveilleux versa c'est
un endroit vous le sentez qu'on
abandonne pas d'un coeur léger
le marbre rose de trianon l'argent des
bassins sous la lune les tapis
multicolore des perspectives ne s'oublie
pas très aisément ni ceux qui restent
ni ce qu'on aime mais vient un jour où
ce qu'on aime ou chasse et l'homme est
ainsi fait qu'il a la force d'aller vers
de nouvelles amours
presque toujours ou d'anciennes amours
quant à celle là madame nous savons
monsieur nous savons enfin nous eûmes
haut mais donnez-moi asseyez vous je
vous en prie à côté de chine a avec
droit si lady sina le permet appelez-moi
china voulez vous voir je donnais une
finale
s'il avait fait d'un grand plaisir en
motorisant avis donné son prénom mais je
ne sais presse effet alors qu'à une
condition c'est qu'elle me donne le mien
avec joueurs pardon avec joie et recul
c'est un nom que je ne mérite pas
complètement
j'ai comme tout le monde fait la guerre
et évoque deux fois je ne suis pas plus
malin qu'un autre mais hélas non mais si
c'est le vôtre je veux certifier la tap
la duchesse quand lemeran wallon ma
maman me cdc un prix doit être mieux
renseigné que vous comment vous
appelez-vous alors horace pourquoi race
mais c'est ainsi madame j'en suis désolé
mais c'est ainsi croyez bien que je n'y
suis pour rien c'est à sa fille je ne
trouve pas non ce n'est pas le prénom
que juste choisi mais il est noble les
romains il est même assez mal et c'était
celui de mon arrière grand père qui
était sous intendant des menus plaisirs
de monseigneur le dauphin vous m'avez
mal compris ce monsieur ce n'est pas
votre prénom qui est insensé mais c'est
que nous ayons parlé debout depuis 48
heures vous appelant hercules et ma
forme je vous demande pardon
j'étais si ému s'est surprise j'ai tout
embrouiller les prénoms les surnoms tout
ceci n'a aucune importance ciena je
finis par me le demandez vous excusez
moi monsieur il faut que j'aille coucher
ses deux marmotte qui souffrent au lit
on peut l'aimer des fergus
nous reviendrons dans un instant dit
bonsoir mes trésors monsieur bonsoir
banal bon cela fausse bombe
et son jeune et charmant ces petits
bonshommes comme votre mais relisez mais
comme elle a raison comment d'ailleurs
ne pas aimer les enfants et je suis plus
une enfant je suis sûr que votre mère
vous adore vous aussi ça c'est quoi
et ça c'est d'être aimé par sa mère
grace il faut que je vous dise je suis
mauvaise jeunes ont bien sûr toutes les
jeunes filles mentent sans pour autant
être mauvaise pour voulez vous être mon
allié il n'y a que vous qui puissiez
vous dirait de la situation atroce
je me suis mise j'ai inventé que vous
m'aimiez vous avez bien faire mais que
vous m'aimiez avec un capital chez nous
on dit avec un grand a
mais je pourrais vous aimez avec un
grand h mais la différence d'âge entre
nous est un peu sensible
oui mais votre grand âge je l'ignorais
quand j'ai inventé notre rencontre à
trianon coupé sous la tonnelle et voilà
on s'enduit un passant s'arrête on le
baptiser hercules et on lui distribuer
le mauvais rôle d'une méchante farce
parlez moi de vous plutôt de vous tous
qui me plaisait tant et toulouse donnez
moi quelque chose à boire je vous prie
que voulez-vous que boîte on va votre
pays
il y à de la pierre noire du gingembre
il y à notre petit poison nationale
whisky autant me faire tout de suite
dites-moi ce grand garçon que votre mère
présente comme son beau fils qui est
beau mais qui n'est pas son fils
il n'est pas bien sûr non plus votre
frère non il n'est pas mon frère me est
un monstre à qui le dites-vous
un monstre que vous haïssez de toute mon
âme bien sûr si fort d'ailleurs que j'ai
voulu que je veux lui faire croire que
tu n'as plus rien à faire dans votre
père c'est un peu agaçant vous savez que
vous deveniez tout toujours ce qu'ils
gagnent ou charab agace toujours mais ne
vous inquiétez pas vous ne m'en voudrez
pas longtemps et si je reste un peu et
qu'on vous fasse encore une fois deux
fois dix fois l'immense chagrin
n'hésitez pas à me le confier il ya des
rôles encore j'aimerais beaucoup jouer
nous verrons je l'espère et el kihel
maman bien vous l'avez vu aperçue elle
nous lève elle nous coucher nous lave
elle nous est évidemment il très bonne
très douces à courageuse très violent et
très terrifiante 13 à doha ils n'ont pas
lui dire monsieur qu'elle est très
adorable elle va le croire et me rendre
encore un peu plus folle d'elle elle
nous allons souper tout sera glacé et
immangeable
ce qui vous étonnera pas notre cuisine
étant paraît-il la risée de l'europe
vous ferez semblant de vous y faire et
comme nous manquons un peu d'hommes dans
cette maison enfin je m'entends vous me
ferez l'honneur de vous asseoir en face
de moi et agité je vous prie cette
petite cloche pour appeler fergus torque
will et méchant mais jean ce qu'il en
reste
je me dis viens d'arriver il dit qu'il
avait monsieur torchwood est au bord du
lac elle se jeter à l'eau il y la nation
au loin comme un fou le jardinier l'a
appelé il n'a pas répondu
il a disparu dans la rue qu'est ce que
vous dites ce que la jardinière materi
votre grave mais ne restez pas planter
la cour et 10 aux jardiniers d'aller
jusqu'au lac et de préparer la barque et
apportez moi un plaid j'arrive
maintenant c'est terrifiant pourquoi y
est je ne crois rien venez avec moi
china s'il ne répond pas à ma voix il
répondra peut-être encore à la vôtre
permettez moi de vous accompagner nous
avons pas ni pour pas faire rester là
prier pour lui et ne bougeait pas
vraiment la raison ne bougeait pas et
taisez vous
je vous en supplie vous avez ma parole
des déments et malade
voilà ce qu'ils sont qu'est ce qu'on
fait ici je vous le demande je me le
demande aussi vous alliez annoncé le
souper je suppose
monsieur le vicomte va pas me dire qu'il
veut se mettre à table
j'appartiens madame un peuple où selon
la légende se recrutent volontiers les
experts en gastronomie est en amour
j'avais donc exercer le premier de ces
dons et me pencher ensuite les idées
plus claires sur les amours contrariées
d'une biche et d'un coq de bruyère
servez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'ennuie ska p m'ennuie c'est quelque
chose
souffrez-vous n'occupera que c'est
fictif faudrait pouvoir il n'a pas coeur
cette panne aucun c'est à vous de jouer
fabius qu'elle me quelle heure est il
[Musique]
5h10 celle là aussi était traqué on va
aller dormir
vous cesserez de vous ennuyer nous
exclamer de vos jérémiades
je ne peux pas rester seul dans ma
chambre quand il ya du toner elle a
perdu du tonnerre à son âge où je dis
monsieur bruce vous avez eu peur du
tonnerre sinon vous seriez leur votre
lit moi je suis petit c'est normal
parfaitement c'est à vous le rejouer
plus encore pendant que le coeur n'y est
plus efficient raconter l'histoire une
histoire j'étais en juge j'ai plus
d'histoires à cette heure-ci pu dire et
histoires drôles du tout alors je peux
cherchera donc aulaqui deux histoires il
m'appelait race à loos il me plaît c'est
y dort les défis vous connaissez bien
que pour qu'il vous plaise temps avec
moi c'est comme ça tout de suite vous
allez encore vous imitez bien maman
pourquoi c'est plus aussi non c'est pas
ça que je voulais dire pourquoi ne sont
elles pas à la maison maman et china
excès se promène mon petit il se promène
alors ça c'est quelque chose oui oui et
se promènent vous entendez au moi ce que
j'en dis tiens justement elles ont fini
se promener ses dames
les voilà qui reviennent
tout seul c'est pas moi parce que rien
manquer vite dans votre chambre très
gentiment un très gentiment comme des
hommes l'un rayé pas peur mais fric va
vous accompagner dépuceler vous jeudi à
sa grâce que le tonnerre ne faisait pas
vrai ça quand je vous dis que le tea
l'orage est passé puis sa grâce vous
ordonne d'accompagner les enfants au lit
sa grâce ne vous le répétera pas deux
fois c'est clair actuelle mais c'est
déjà trop a cessé de me tripoter je suis
ami mais il va rentrer je vous jure qui
va rentrer il a il a perdu la tête je ne
perdais pas l'amour
pénélope qu'est ce qui vous prend
venez leur chair pénélope précieux speed
up
mais vous êtes mort ah c'est vrai mon
ami que je suis morte mais enfin
pourquoi torque où il veut et il me tue
que lui achever rien amélie tout aussi
au moins je pouvais vous aider à coire
non mais
et tout et rien n'est perdu on peut on
peut vouloir galoper dans le vent on
peut vouloir s'enfuir souffrir rêver
mais ailleurs rêver rêver nous parler à
une ancienne virtuose du rêve ne
l'oublié pas mais n'oubliez pas non plus
que vous parlez d'un homme que vous
n'avez jamais traité en sommes bel et
loeb alors accepté accepter quoi
accepter qu'un enfant de 20 ans à égal à
mort après qu'on ait passé vingt ans à
lui apprendre à vivre avant vous
acceptez assez facilement permettez moi
de vous dire c'est bien vite accepté
tout la visite d'un étranger dans
l'inconnu nous plonge dans l'horreur
comment lui en vouloir en effet à dieu
que je suis fatigué dans mon coeur
fergus et quel chemin encore à parcourir
en tenant à bout de bras
toutes ces existences autour de la
mienne ces existences qui finissent vous
et dur
messi messi qui finissent regardez-vous
monde ces autres qui commencent et sept
autres encore avec laquelle on joue pour
se venger peut-être pour me punir pour
me punir de toujours décidé de toujours
entreprendre ah c'est vrai mon enfant
que je suis mort noah chi l'epec vie et
saint-brice d'abord où est il
les dix cinémas dame taquile taux recule
mon enfant vous êtes là vous êtes revenu
qu'avez vous fait regardez ma regardez
maintenant il est vert vous n'êtes pas
malade vous n'êtes pas blessé non
mesdames il n'est pas malade il va même
très bien aux malades
qu'en savez-vous monsieur comment ne
serait-il pas mal après cette nuit dans
l'eau cette nuit glacée cette nuit-là
traces même moment nous sommes dans juin
thor queen dit comment vous vous sentez
dit très bien comment très bien oui très
bien très bien c'est un peu fort
bungie madame très bien après m'avoir
fait vieillir de 20 en quelques heures
très bien oh c'est un art vous avez une
rue de santé c'est un peu facile d'aller
très bien très bien on croit rêver
les six n'ont pas pu aller boire et
manger quelque chose avec votre frère et
prenez un peu de repos nous en avons
tous un immense besoin jeudi un fol moi
manger dormir aussi peut-être alors que
j'étais encore où et comment vous avez
mis la main sur mon fils en regardant en
l'air
il était sur une branche il met
pratiquement tombé dans les bras quand
j'ai dit son nom
kaka le droit l'appeliez vous pourquoi
fallait-il que ce soit avouent qu'ils
répondent vous que personne ne
connaissait encore ici jusqu'à hier soir
peut-être que le bruit de mais pas sur
les feuilles l'effrayer moins de vos
menaces et voies lamentations parce que
ce n'est pas en sonnant de la trompe à
tout propos et hors de propos qu on
rameute les gens qu'on dit aimer plus
que tu as brice comment osez vous me
parler sur ce ton
comment osez vous retrouver mon fils en
un instant alors que china et moi muant
lionceaux n'ont depuis des heures
puisque nous parlons de china
trouvez-vous très élégant de conter
fleurette sur une place publique à une
petite fille est carré en france
permettez moi de ne pas répondre il est
vain de mon honneur et cesser de jouer
le sergent recruteur la mère éplorée et
la souveraine offensé men et relance sa
drisse jeu c'est un mot de plus et
j'appelle vous appelez qui deux
bonshommes de 8 ans du vieillard de 80
que vous terroriser une jeune fille trop
romanesque
un garçon de 20 ans que vous n'avez pas
vu devenir un homme
l'essai craquer vos nerfs madame et
redevenait la femme que vous n'auriez
jamais dû cesser d'être
c'est moi qui vous demande un peu de
silence
un peu de douceur un peu de chaleur
liège par droit après ce que j'ai subi
dans mon pays après l'accueil pour le
moins inattendue que j'ai retiré d'un
bourg
donnez-moi dame m'ayez pas peur
regardez
voyez vous bien ce que je vois je ne
vois rien rien qu'un visage détruit des
yeux battus jusqu'au menton
je ne vois pas où vous voulez en venir
vous avez de la chance de la chance
oui vous avez de la chance d'être dans
votre grande île inaccessible où rien ne
vous dérange comme vous avez de la
chance de n'être pas une femme de chez
nous de celle à qui on demande jamais
leur avis ou six rames de celles qui on
ordonne d'être belle et ans et qui ont
cette merveilleuse faiblesse obéir à
l'homme qu'elle aime je vous supplie de
vous taire je parle mais laissez moi
vous dire qu'il y à là devant nous celle
que vous n'auriez pas dû oublier
elle est encore là bien vivante
je vous laisse devant cette belle image
prenez en soin
pour prendre soin de soi il faut un vrai
prétexte
je n'en ai plus depuis bien bien
longtemps
vous aviez raison vous n'avez vraiment
rien vu dans ce miroir
adieu madame
[Applaudissements]
je tire à sa faire savoir à sa grâce ce
que la patience a des limites et que la
mienne ayant atteint ses limites
je m'en retourne annonce pourrait être
une bonne nouvelle mais avant de vous on
retourner à londres
vous allez vous en retournez dans votre
cuisine et y demeurer jusqu'à nouvel
ordre
où dort quand ici lorsque tel est mon
bon plaisir
suivez-moi reste dans l'ombre
[Applaudissements]
quand vous revenu peu importe à qui
faites-vous signé un ami je ne veux pas
qui vous prend ne veux pas qu'il soit
votre ami tu as l'air et qu'il soit
notre ami à la rigueur peut-être at-il
une opinion à ce sujet je me moque de
son opinion pourquoi parce que je vous
déteste tous les deux vous n'êtes pas
trop fatigué de tous détestés
si je peux vous n'avez pas trop sommeil
non vous n'avez pas trop froid non vous
êtes content d'être rentré
oui presque vous sentez bien gentil
aimable
mon dieu pourquoi ne pensez vous pas
plus souvent vos nuits sur la branche
d'un arbre
pourquoi pour être plus souvent gentil
aimable bien original un jour vous
partirez oui je partirai
vous partirez vous serais heureuse avant
que vous ne partiez avant que vous ne
découvriez le bonheur je voudrais vous
demander pardon et vous dire adieu quand
je voudrais vous demander pardon de
n'avoir pas su me dépêcher de prendre la
main que vous avez tendu à un autre j'ai
pensé toute cette nuit à la chine a de
mon enfance et je me disais que c'était
beaucoup de chance d'avoir le droit
d'aimer sa soeur j'avais ce droit je
n'ai pas su en profiter
vous n'avez pas su mais vous serez
peut-être un jour quand vous saurez que
les petits signes que l'on fait par une
fenêtre peuvent être des signes d'adieu
fantômes ou un rêve qu'est ce que vous
dites il ya vérité un homme non non non
non pas ministre avoue t il ainsi à 6h30
du matin une histoire en quoi êtes-vous
construis mes garçons ailleurs pikinois
nuno continu continu est d'abord où en
étais-je et alors et alors quoi ces
cookies rajouter ce n'est pas moi oui
mais alors est alors en china china
prenez le relais voulez vous savez je ne
fais plus d'histoire ah bon bon ben
alors alors oui alors chez mon pauvre
papa quand j'étais tout petit vous étiez
tout peut être perdu on vous défendez
sans doute de jouer avec le feu il tenu
ce flambeau vous avez l'air d'un fou et
vous le dites c'est où les matins vraie
maman ranvin d'ailleurs osé vous la
brousse est un art vous avez les mains
propres
non elles sont sales david à ségou et
reprenons la vie où nous l'avions
laissée
vous prenez bien des libertés a chéri
vous auriez pris les mêmes moments il
fallait bien à horace un refuge ou
atteindre attendre quoi mon dieu mes
enfants à moi madame avec votre
permission des enfants vous avez des
enfants
pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas dit plus tôt
mais nous avons été un peu bousculée
petit enfin bien là combien 4 c'est
peut-être beaucoup pas pouvoir jouer la
vraie guerre avec des unis réitèrent à
charny sprick rome était le couvert de
monsieur le vicomte savais que je vois
votre maintenant que marc hard et enfin
rassembler
faites moi le plaisir de vous asseoir en
face de moi aura ce jeu vous avez guère
faire cette place ce sera désormais la
vôtre si vous le voulez bien
[Musique]
la pièce que nous avons eu le plaisir de
jouer a été écrite et mise en scène par
jacques françois
le décor et de rage et art
[Applaudissements]
les costumes de donald cardwell
avec rodolphe marin
fabrice botrel
[Applaudissements]
patrick laplace
catherine salviat
[Applaudissements]
madeleine barbelés
jean pierre meybon
claude dauphin
lise de la marque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]